well welcome we are in the world's first
national video market mine's Ian I'm the
director and mother got a woman folks at
work here and this is what you see when
you come in the first thing is a massive
blue blue hedgehog just walk over he'll
tell you all the games that are in here
it changes all the times there's tons to
play but it's all about playing is is
all about making games so the big thing
about this place is and we can everybody
should go to play games but also Yuri
like people knowing how to make them -
you see these fantastic people at this
desk they'll say hello to you just like
this so he's actually like that there
are arcade machines to play there are
all things to do - and then I mean the
kind of Kuna thing about the building is
there's lots of stuff that's only here
so a lot of games are we've commissioned
that you can only H play in this
building first one you'll see is this
one she called - and Bosch this is only
a nursery but it's made by an artist put
Allister Aitchison it's fantastic game
that allows you to spot these symbols
you have to bash other people about the
way and battery a bash the buttons to
get to the right one before anybody else
does so we really wanted to like kind of
right away show people the games aren't
necessarily just about kind of standing
where this they can be about bashing
things - unless pretty what we wanted to
cry and do with this a lots people do
this is kind of warm up you might want
to come through here into the toaster by
now it's not just a clever name the
toast bar is called the chest behind the
step because it will it has a variety of
toast that it will indeed venue and lots
again of games for you to play 10 to the
older stuff and here's my Nintendo 64
you can request a different game from
the bar if you want to in the summer
it's nice in the summer right outside
I need some totally sure like welcome
you as much as we as much as we possibly
can so come in and out here so the
Mission Control this is a game about
making games so the idea here is a
two-player game an ad whilst two people
play other people could be changing it
so you can kind of change the graphics
you can change the gravity you can
change the spawn rate of aliens kind of
really gently get people in this idea
that they can change and what games are
I really see what games are made of so
weird thing about games is you don't
often get don't even get kind of look
inside the kitchen like other things are
just here this is room races this is
fantastic game my elite of belt oven
this is like Micro Machines but the
magical part of is I just start this up
for you by the red car here racing
around but this is a cool part anything
we put down the car crashes into so you
end up with like a couple of different
games how many one of them's like a
racing game and although it'll be people
lying on here to be kind of raced around
so anything that we pass through so it's
kind about two things is about playing
games and racing cars it's about what
makes a good race track right this is
that kind of big main stairwell that
goes up and down low to the buildings
and when you design a museum like often
what people do is trying to hide the
computers and hide the way that it was
and we come in the opposite way we want
to do is expose everything so even if
even if you don't really know about
electronics like you can see that all of
the orange stuff is power right all the
Purple's network so simply all the
exhibits that we built here we if they
break and they do break sometimes um we
just fix them in front of you because
you can you can do that we're trying to
capture the I suppose the sort of spirit
of like when I was a kid if the video
recorder broke we'd have the back off it
in the kitchen table you know you can
put it back together in but you have to
go at fixing it it's that kind of idea
of like being out of open stuff up and
it sort of kind of x-ray it and really
kind of get involved with what we're
trying to do um so the whole building we
wanted to make kind of transparent so
gallery 2 is the hall of inputs I
ranging from like really like the kind
of controllers that you might be used to
having at home
game of trials weather weather quite
complicated but nonetheless thing you
might recognize export controller to
arcade machines two joysticks and
buttons you'll be familiar with that
they are two mouse and keyboard games in
general journal is the fate of Atlantis
for tastic adventure game 2 text
adventures with twine to light gun games
at time crises and comets cockpit games
of driving games that threw the Star
Wars or Sonic races to the music rooms
it's kind of rock band guitar heroes we
get quite a hand in it quite loud in
history of return the time and this is
one of my favorite bits so this is them
this is the kind of wall of inputs this
is for games always quite different no
control mechanisms so we've got version
of a game called
tempest tip which is using a spinner
which you spin around to shoot the
aliens yeah so a single button game oh
I'm not very good at it though terrible
in this game and a track ball game so
miss our commands so sorry you may
remember this so you're moving the
crosshair around with a trackball so
they're all played in quite different
ways I'm always trying to do it's like
in a really gentle way here just get
people to think about the fact that not
all games are controlled with a kind of
controller that you might have at home
there's loads and loads of different
interfaces if I kind of jet we change
these around quite often and chase it
games around change controllers around
to just kind of gently draw attention to
the fact that IV assumptions that you
might have about when your gameplay it's
gonna be true a lot of people either
play with a keep it on a mouse will they
play with that you know play with it I
play with a gamepad and there's so many
different things that games up so we
have kind of smaller installations on
these rooms so these change around every
few months we'll put a different kind of
more experience your game in there right
now it's panoramic or she's got a
generative music game by the late 60s on
the wall freeze and then we move up to
gallery 3 so this is our most kind of
gallery like gallery I guess the problem
with exhibiting video games they're
probably talking to people about video
games is that quite often like they rely
on you as the custom of being good at
video games if I want to talk to you
about Sonya her job right and show you
what
edge of yours but hand your controller
and let you play something ahead you're
gonna hope that you are good at signing
the hedgerow because you're not you like
work we have to see this bit so what
we're trying to do with these little
game inspectors as experiment with
giving people snapshots specific ideas
within games to experience so this is
gang visas he hasn't played gang beasts
you must immediately get down race has
been made in Sheffield it's a kind of
drunk jelly babies fighting in a car
park physics brawler game a chemical
bomb low like I was a bone loaf made for
us a game is better
so this is a demo showing you play the
game over there and over here you can
play around with seeing how the physics
work so you can see as he turns red at
the collision points and you can also
see how the animation which is working
so you can see actually what this person
do is rolling around on ball when
animated get a much better sense of V so
this is a look like inside again that
you're play over there you'll just never
normally see one things I always liked
about it like exhibits of classical
things it's actually the sketchbooks
rather than the finishings you know
they're kind of working it out and
having been so in here I'm we invite any
developer to show work and that's not
finished yet right so people get to
place that before it's done they leave
some suggestions in the end up in the
developers box so people get to see
games before they're done and then
feedback amend and then just be able to
say things like what you mean faster or
slower is too hard or the colors aren't
right and it's like it's the look inside
games that most of the public never
really get the most I mean you encounter
Gammage shrink-wrap to this finish
beautiful just exposing again this fact
that there are things that are made it's
really really important this is the
green house and then I'm most kind of
gallery like Gary this is a history of
video games in a hundred at least
objects roughly a hundred objects I mean
it's like a loosely chronological
journey around staying here so whenever
people come in they will gravitate
towards the area they recognize this
will be my childhood right here and
again these are all machines that people
can play we have a bit of a bit of basic
on the window if people want to have a
go at programming of BBC I'm always
really like delighted and surprised with
the amount of time that people spend in
here they like people of a certain age
I'm like me we spent quite a lot of time
along this wall we'd be trying to show
this sort of social history of games too
so things like this may mean not mean
much to some of you but things like
pirated cassettes from the 80s with kind
of hand-drawn schoolboy artwork things
like maps from video games things like
kind of spin off board games and
keyboard over laser and kind of I guess
the sort of ephemera of what games are
and what games meant to people is really
what this this room is trying to capture
this was just about again you know kind
of kind of playing things but also some
things like the Lara's aid donated by no
less in Ian Livingstone doomed to master
like couple we say John Romero turned up
here so John Romero was was a co desire
of doom like the seminal first-person
shooter and this is really one of the
gold masters of doom to like incredibly
influential designer
yeah just rocked up first thing I though
I was at home first thing we heard about
was somebody like saying with the single
slack of usually internal message on
Romero's in the building and everyone
like went nuts needed a little talk here
for some of the some of the dads to
recognize who he was it's quite for a
special moment people tend to spend you
know kind of color like most of the day
here when they come and that combined
with things like the classes if you've
got kids you won't want to learn
oh there comes some sightly mornings
that pixel out clubs during the week and
lots and lots of events that happen in
the evenings for every group we're
trying to be a guest sort of community
center really for people interested in
this kind of stuff you know drink
football you can join a football club
which is a music you can join Orchestra
just in games technologies and culture
but come here and hand help us help us
make it better so that's an actual
really go market we'd like to thank
audible for sponsoring this episode of
computer foul and if you go to
audible.com slash computerphile
there's a chance to sign up and get a
free audiobook it's important to use
this URL which is here to sign up using
some kind of desktop machine and after
that you can sign in on an app we've
download the app onto your device and
and start browsing listening to books I
was gonna recommend a type ratshit book
today but this is my first time using
this app and there are so many options
that I might change my mind
Stephen Fry get started so thanks once
again to audible.com and check out
audible.com slash computerphile be a
free book if I obtain a cookie of you
which is supposed to be secure then I
can send that to let's say Amazon or to
a shop and say I'm sure and please you
know what's in the shopping basket
what's his address
what's his credit card details